Hey, Joanna, did you notice this?
Well, talk back is pretty repetitive for
this list.
Can you call Dan?
>> Yeah.
>> Hey folks.
What's up?
>> Just wondering if you
looked at talk back support?
>> I think we did something.
I remember something about
content descriptions.
>> Well, the content
descriptions are pretty awkward.
Not very helpful.
This is basic accessibility stuff and.
>> This is why we're here, right guys?
To help make sure Sunshine is
a great app for all of its users.
>> Yeah, totally agreed and
not at all intentional.
This is something that
should never be an Apple
product-
>> Hey,
I'd be happy to take care of making
Sunshine accessible, but, Dan,
does that mean you forgot to
do localization work as well?
Got it.
Okay, I'll take care of that as well.
Sound good?
>> Good, good.
I'm going to go out and
test sunshine outside,
and try out these new improvements.
They do seem like they
will be really helpful.
Nice work, Dan.